سياده اللواء ارتفاع عدد القتلى وتجاوز
هذا العدد الى حد ال 500 هذا تقريبا يقترب
من عدد قتلى الجيش الاسرائيلي خلال حرب 67
حينما خاضت اسرائيل حربا ضد ست دول عربيه
ماذا تقرا في هذا الرقم حتى
الان يعني هذا بالتاكيد يسجل لصالح
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقدراتها القتاليه
ومهاراتهم الميدانيه وخططها الاستراتيجيه
والتكتيكات التي تم
استخدامها من قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه وهو
تراجع ايضا في كفاءه الجيش الاسرائيلي
القتاليه وفي تدني روحه المعنويه ونحن نح
منذ اليوم الاول قلنا ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
اذا ما دخل قطاع غزه سيدخل بروح قتاليه
متدنيه وبمعني محطمه لانه هزم يوم 77 على
ايدي المقاتلين الفلسطينيين وخاصه
بالنموذج
فرقه غزه وهي نخبه النخبه التي هزمت في
مواقعها المحصنه في ثكناتها وتم يعني
السيطره على كل مواقعها واسر عدد كبير من
قياداتها فبالتالي جاء الجندي الاسرائيلي
مهزوما وجاء ايضا بعقيده هني بعل انه اما
اسير او قتيل وهو ما يجري على ارض الواقع
وهو الذي دفع نخبه النخبه من الانسحاب
وخاصه اللواء الجولاني في حي الشجاعيه ا س
سياده اللواء بعد تجاوز ايضا الشهرين على
العمليه البريه التي شنتها اسرائيل على
القطاع وقالت ان هدفها او من بين اهدافها
المعلنه الى جانب تدمير حماس واستعاده
الاسرى تامين البلدات المحاذيه لقطاع غزه
اليوم تبث القسام بعد اكثر من شهرين من
هذه العمليه رشقه صاروخيه تطلق من شمال
القطاع يفترض ان هذه المناطق قد تم
الاستيلاء عليها ثم تطهير ثم تمشيطها ثم
يعني هذا الامر متكرر بشكل لفت للنظر ايضا
ماذا تقرا في
هذا اخي محمود اعتقد انه الجواب على سؤالك
من كان من الداخل الاسرائيلي يعني باراك
جاوب عليه حالوتس جاوب عليه اولمرت جاب
عليه كلهم اجابوا بان الجيش الاسرائيلي
حتى الان لم يحقق انجازات على ارض الواقع
والهدف المعلن القضاء على المقاومه
الفلسطينيه او حتى تفكيكها كما يقال في
الاونه الاخيره اصبح من المستحيل يعني
الجندي الاسرائيلي الان رغم ان هناك
100000 جندي اسرائيلي لهم 85 يوم يتمدد في
قطاع غزه غير قادر على السيطره على الارض
غير قادر على الدفاع عن نفسه يعني شاهدنا
اشرطه الفيديو كيف يلاحق المقاومين
الفلسطينيين الدبابات والجنود
الاسرائيليين في كل مكان وصلوا اليه
فبالتالي ما دام 100,000 جندي اسرائيلي
غير قادرين على الدفاع عن انفسهم في حمايه
الطائرات والمدفعيه البريه والمدفعيه
البحريه والدبابات فكيف سيكون حال
المستوطنين اذا ما عادوا الى غلاب قطاع غز
وانا اعتقد انه قالوا كلمتهم انه ما دام
هكذا وضع في في قطاع غزه وما دام الجيش
الاسرائيلي لم يحقق اهدافه ولم يحقق
انجازات على الارض لن نعود وانا بتقديري
يعني خبراء ومحللين عسكريين كتبوا كثير
خاصه اليوم اليوم كانت معظم المقالات
تتحدث عن ان العمليه العسكريه لم تحقق اي
انجاز على ارض الواقع فبالتالي اذا ما كان
اربع فرق او خمس فرق حتى اليوم خمس فرق
عسكريه غير قادره على الدفاع عن نفسها في
قطاع غزه فكيف سيكون الحال في الغلاف وفي
المستوطنات
جرى او اعلنا ان كتائب القسام تمكنت من
الاستيلاء على طائره طائره استطلاع
اسرائيليه من طراز سكاي لارك
اثنان وشاهدنا في الفيديو المصور الذي
بثته
الكتائب عمليه تفكيك هذه الطائره هل هناك
امكانيه من خلال الهندسه العكسيه
الاستفاده من التكنولوجيا الموجوده في مثل
هذه الطائرات واعاده تصنيعها لصالح
القسام يعني ما شاهدناه اخي محمود من خلال
التجربه في عمليه طوفان الاقصى يوم 17 حتى
اليوم هناك معر عقول وادم وهناك تطور نوعي
عند المقاومه الفلسطينيه يعني ل نسوق اخي
محمود مثلا الصواريخ هناك صواريخ كانت
عمياء تسمى عمياء بمعنى انها لم تنفجر هذه
الصواريخ العمياء التي تم اعاده تدويرها
وتحويلها الى الغام فاعله ووضعت تحت دبابه
المركبه في نفس اليوم تقريبا خلال 48 ساعه
من سقوطها على الارض وتم يعني تفجير
الدبابه دبابه المركبه من الصواريخ
الامريكيه التي استخدمتها الطائرات
الاسرائيليه ولم تنفجر فبالتالي هذا ان دل
على شيء يدل على ان هناك فكر متطور متقدم
متنور واعتقد انه الذي اعد لخطه طوفان
الاقصى لمده ثلاث سنوات وبرعى في تدريب
الش المقاتلين ومهارات ميدانيه وقتاليه
ومعركه عقول وادم وخدعه تضليل واستراتيجيه
وت تنفيذ بارع على الارض يعني بالتنسيق
بين البر والبحر والجو والسيطره على 20
فكنه عسكريه انا اعتقد هذا المستوى يؤكد
بان يعني باب الاحتمالات مفتوح على مصرعيه
بان هذه المقاومه لديها القدرات العاليه
في الاستفاده والتصنيع وتطوير والتطوير
وقد شاهدنا يعني يعني قاذف الياسين قاذف
الياسين هو يشابه الار بي جي 29 يعني احدث
انواع الار بيجي الروسي وفعاليته كما هو
فعاليه الار بي جي 29 وكذلك كل كل ال
التصنيع المحلي للمقاومه الفلسطينيه ثبت
براعته وخاصه لغم الشواظ لغم لغم الشواظ
يزن 25 كيلو ويفجر دبابه المركا فه يعني
100 دولار مقابل ملايين من الدولارات
وفعاليه وقتل واصابه دقيقه